comme le sénat où l'assemblée
nationale le parlement européen est
composé de différents groupes
politiques
une fois élu après les élections de
juin 2009 et les députés des
vingt-sept états membres vont donc on
rejoindra l'un de ces groupes en
fonction de leurs affinités politiques
mais attention à groupe ce n'est pas un
parti alors pour simplifier un groupe
comprend des députés appartenant
à des partis politiques européens
nationaux
le parlement européen est composé
outre de ce groupe politique ces groupes
politiques représentés des tendances
partisanes tel qu'on le trouve
dans les différents états membres à
titre d exemple le pp le parti populaire
européen et le groupe majoritaire
aujourd'hui au sein du parlement
européen
% et se situe à roye de l'échiquier
politique alors on trouve également le
parti socialiste européen qui comme son
nom l'indiqué au plan sont départis de
l'état membre le groupe des
écologistes verts groupe des libéraux
l'ump qui se singularise par orléans
sur deux
le brouillage un petit plus logique
entre le centre droit la droite
libérale
à un moment on peut penser également
à l'arrière gauche unitaire qui est au
bout groupe les partis d'extrême gauche
par exemple parti communiste français
ou encore le modèle unique allemand
pour ce qui concerne la france l'ump et
se retrouve au sein du parti populaire
européen le modèle au sein du groupe
des libéraux le parti socialiste
français au sein du groupe du parti les
socialistes européens
pour le parti d écologie se retrouve
évidemment au sein d'une ligne dure aux
politiques divergent
les présidents des principaux groupes
politiques au sein du parlement
européen sont pour le pp joseph daul
kim qui est français
même martine choses simples pour les
socialistes qui est allemand monica face
à nice à l'atelier de la comédie qui
co-préside le groupe la politique des
verts au sein du ps et perdra moins que
seul le britannique qui préside le
groupe rebelle des libéraux
il fallait jusque-là cinq autres
députés étaient six pays différents
pour constituer un groupe mais la règle
rien de changé
jaffray jean 2009 m il faudra au minimum
25 et le député de cette paix il
différent pour constituer un groupe
politique au parlement européen
c'est toute la question de savoir si les
conservateurs britanniques qui
aujourd'hui
sont membres du parti populaire
européen
il faut faire scission donc pour
affaiblir le parti populaire européen
ils vont réussir à créer outre pas un
nouveau groupe politique non seulement
avec le tchèque de liesse avec une
polonaise du piste mais aussi pour que
ce groupe soit rendue possible avec
d'autres d'autres partis dans d'autres
états membres le lien ce stade à ce
jour il est difficile de savoir si
cette condition visant à réunir un
monde pas suffisamment important sera
réunie
à la pompe
plus improbable emportant un fusil 13
ans au moment du vote dans l'hémicycle
les grands comptes aussi davantage de
moyens pour travailler
il dispose d'un secrétariat de
facilités administratives et de
crédits prévus au budget du parlement
si vous êtes
dans un groupe politique
alors
vous avez accès à la répartition
des postes
de la machine parlementaire
la présidence les vice-présidents 5
surtout
commission les présidences de
commissions qui sont absolument car il a
de la commission étant
le mode d'existence le plus important du
parlement 736 députés santé en juin
prochain mais il faudra attendre le 14
juillet jour de la première session
parlementaire
pour connaître la composition de ce
nouveau parlement européen